Pues eso implica que habrá un bloqueo
legislativo es decir los republicanos sí
podrían llamar a investigaciones si
podrían llamar investigar a indagatoria
a demócratas y a otros políticos en el
país se podrían avanzar con su agenda
política agenda política sin embargo que
a la hora de ellos presentar proyectos
de ley Pues Posiblemente sea bloqueada
por un senado de mayoría
demócrata podrían pasar por ejemplo en
esta agenda demócrata que tiene los
republicanos
se incluye temas por ejemplo como
recortes en el gasto del gobierno se
incluye también esta gente republicana
temas como avanzar en la exploración
petrolera y también en Pues implementar
otra vez códigos Fiscales y códigos
tributarios que venían de la época del
ex presidente Donald Trump sin embargo
Pues esa agenda será posiblemente
bloqueada por esa mayoría demócrata
Aunque tienen entonces la posibilidad de
investigar tienen entonces la
posibilidad de llamar indagatoria no van
a poder avanzar mucho su agenda Dado que
los demócratas tienen el senado Este es
el fin también de posiblemente Nancy
pelosi como presidenta de la cámara de
representantes teniendo en cuenta que
pues ya fue aprobado de forma interna el
nuevo presidente de la cámara de
representantes Kevin mccarthy Bueno ya
usted lo estaba mencionando y sabíamos
que si se lograba esta mayoría
repúblicanal lo más probable era que
Kevin mccarthy Rental reemplazará a
Nancy pelosi como presidente de la
cámara de representantes que falta
entonces para que mccarthy sea
confirmado
Pues ahora una brotación en pleno es
decir los
435 congresistas nuevos se reunirán la
primera semana de enero para confirmar a
Kevin mccarthy tendrán que Kevin
Mccartney asegurar al menos 218 votos
para Pues confirmarse en el cargo de
presidente de la cámara de
representantes y este punto es
importante porque la votación interna
del partido republicano
188 republicanos apoyaron a Kevin
mccarthy en contra de la persona que el
que espera contrincante para quedarse
también en la silla de presidente de la
cámara de representantes y 38 38
congresistas republicanos votaron en
contra de Kevin mccarthy y esto muestra
que nuevamente hay una división interna
en el partido republicano pero muestra
que Kevin mccarthy no se puede dar el
lujo de perder muchas sillas en esta
votación en plenaria muchas escaños
teniendo en cuenta además que los
demócratas claramente van a votar en
contra de Kevin Mccartney en contra de
su candidatura ya confirmada Por los
republicanos Pero entonces pues le queda
un trabajo bastante ardua que hoy
mccarthy en las próximas semanas para
asegurar estos 218 votos que necesita
para poder ser confirmado como
presidente de la cámara de
representantes